okay [ __ ] we're back oh let's stay
there for a while okay I bet what do you
want and i'll come by for that drink you
offer that's all I wasn't really serious
about that what you're here whatever sit
yeah I gonna rob me again man I never
robbed you I was just a repossession I'm
kidding because whatever you want to
call it I was lit on here [ __ ]
helicopters can do for you see I just
came by to see if this time I can help
you with I see you doing well for
yourself look I'm retired ain't you
would be going for the pipe slippers and
staying at a [ __ ] sunset you know
I've been in this game for a lot of
years I got out of life and makes me the
right age okay you look like a good kid
if you want my advice give a [ __ ] up you
work hard screw over everybody that you
love hurt Rob kill indiscriminately and
maybe just maybe if you're lucky you
become a 3-bit gangster it's [ __ ] go
to college then you can rip people off
get pay for it ok call capitalist
so what I saw the other day was like
when of course briefly reanimates itself
and terrorizes everyone right what you
saw the other day was a guy feeling with
past guess I never saw myself as just a
[ __ ] past well today's lesson is all
about humility tomorrow we'll try a
training montage by training what not I
just lost in an 80s movie fantasy yeah i
can see you spend a lot of time here as
much as i can so that's why you can't
buy wood things right maybe i'm here
because i'm just an idiot thinks that
imported palm trees or a good substitute
for not really knowing what the [ __ ] you
doing on this earth and yes yes see a
good time you know that i'll tell you
what look at the chains are like least I
can do is buy you that beer this little
bar I like not too far from here let's
go all right I'm following you at [ __ ]
we're taking my wife's car hey Jim I'm
going for a drink that [ __ ] I mean are
so going down the western Iowa it's
stolen what the yotz been stolen Wow
trying to sell in a car no you didn't
want it so but I need money and they
don't want to buy it they just want to
take it hiding in the head you're insane
alright I'm coming for my boat all right
change of plan my darling boy is in
trouble at city of it
lesson number one don't ever have kids
hey Maya cheese I don't think no panting
issues with a ride over had both
negative and who don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the bathroom [ __ ] they got that
desperate huh huh but no [ __ ] i was
making a point solid eyes until
deprecation i know it well yeah man well
[ __ ] went a motive little [ __ ] man idea
there's somewhere on the western highway
Thank You 100 side of the water yeah I
am you can always find another boat yet
so my account that maybe you can always
get credit for one but have you come
repo'ing don't think alright home ain't
your homie I'm someone you want to
impress real man I'm sultry sorrowful
mother Christmas slip away [ __ ]
[ __ ] I still teach you a thing or two
maybe help you open the door to almond
joys and so related pair I'm a lonely
spot it work those are my help you get
this boat back right that you are my
friends
acha here there
oh there there there it is that's my and
one that's my smoke so both in a [ __ ]
her head yeah we'll we'll catch him we
gotta play sure once I get in the foot
you're the bored part more like to
follow any traffic court you'll be fine
anything happens I got a piece the glove
box I'll cover
ok [ __ ] here
well said you want to learn the old way
to do it it's your oh yeah Franklin
[ __ ] job
oh there there there it is that's my
clothes so boasting a [ __ ] heart man
yeah well we'll catch ya we're gonna get
this [ __ ] we got a plan yeah this is
looking to cut the captivating game but
I don't like reprieve why the fall any
traffic party you'll be fine thing
happen
no you thought of everything right let
me thank you all are no way of doing
this
what the hell
oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ] on
[ __ ]
aw kid
damn
yeah over there the [ __ ] are you soon
and that's all Apple that mean
okay what the [ __ ] they do it
and I [ __ ] you
Oh
okay see ya oh [ __ ] hi yeah we
Kimmy
crew ah ok look you better off see some
tea worthy
give me a negative boom ah oh we killed
that guy you [ __ ] dead come on ah
[ __ ]
I know here magic
I can't jump that
you began let's stop this ship sailing
now that doesn't sound good hey left
hinge in there we take getting this leg
hold it together ah [ __ ] it falls out
done hey stop stop back your dog Bob
there get the ride let's get the ship
[Music]
soon about it
whoa no not that
the wonder I can't give drops is all
oh yeah thank you can get a passbook my
seller my clothes some gangbangers I
know it sounds so when you put it like
that
I love but you're an ass and right now
with my boat disappeared over the
horizon that's all I can see right
through me a spare key just you know
ride on that conviction thing I want to
head but the road great
ah cute it does oh no problem not enough
all right this car is so by Franklin you
call me a cab
no problem
hey I need a cab at something you can
save one most laptops cups by the
airport all right hang loose [ __ ] like I
gotta prank you hey no you r do much got
it not anymore no I don't before me man
now not really this little [ __ ] stays in
his room all day and I don't have any
other people to go with help I like
looking at looking yeah yeah I come down
to the marina sit on the dot pour myself
a drink and look at yeah yeah go ahead
no let me dream Jacqueline huh well
maybe you need to do some other
statistics for your time three mother's
dreams man yeah sure whatever
[Music]
yeah I really started it was all like
some people I know she's doing man st.
ha you don't look at I think what's in
my pocket a couple thousand bucks now
cover it right so you sure you're good
yeah I got this thank i do mother get
out and walk around so Kerrigan's climb
over close man i'm gonna get the ride
fixed man he dropped it back off at your
house along with this dude it's all good
though man you go get your hair right
all right all right listen thanks for
today I appreciate it you stop back out
tonight's will talk you see so man hey
sorry win get your boat man yeah come on
man let's trick this whip homie huh this
car is [ __ ] up the wheels off quicker
oh it's [ __ ] up all right because
sorted it me too did look pretty oh [ __ ]
that's where it's at
good got so I'm doing for now
alright man I'm taking you all it's
Franklin right yeah it's right on the
credit for our guy the home invader you
know what call me what you like me yeah
I know I I mean sure Jimmy I rj Jimmy
yeah hey Mike you don't nah man i was
taking him home so uh what's the deal
man huh you and my old man i see you at
the dealership and someone steals my
wish i was all like he's been down there
talking you guys your coffee and water
talk what'd he do look man if he ain't
here I go here but I lost my [ __ ] job
and I thought maybe we can help me find
a look my dad
is that left dad is retired like Chloe
like these only marketable skills are
watching TV and beef from drinking man
look I don't know home these things okay
to me anything you say man nah nah man
well well Maggie we could have to get
you know I makes me can get [ __ ] done we
could step if it keeps him out of the
house that's cool by me yeah well we'll
see look I'm sorry my dad lost to your
job it's hard after him ha I mean I'm
employment in your challenge at the
moment oh you got fired room hey that's
rough not
not fire discussion I didn't get a shot
I've been there on you be putting the
resumes out here but no one I know I am
I didn't get a job I've never had a job
it feels like hard work my days just
kind of disappear hey you playing right
to slaughter nah not since the first
couple you know so like since you're
both unemployed like we could run
together you know yeah I think about it
home or we could just like shopping you
know Wade on sore get our drink on strip
club come on dude I get real crazy yeah
I got your number [ __ ] I needed man but
um hey you know what Mako he's down your
pops all right all right church exactly
man my brother from another mother I
mean I hope so cuz my mom was kind of
skank back in the day see you yeah
whatever homie shed
mission pass thank you thank you